i think the villain is gonna have a
change of heart
that's right yeah the theme seems to
imply
that yeah and i can totally imagine now
the montage of like you know early on in
our ancient history there was just a
thing that we couldn't get over and and
i wish we had done it better but then it
created this conflict we don't need to
be fighting
and then they'll come together john
they're asian do the asian voice
come on white man do the asian
he doesn't have to do it thank you craig
for a second i thought i was gonna have
to try
how's it going reject nation we're gonna
watch the trailer today for disney's
rhea and the last dragon warner brothers
released their trailer
for their monsters and now disney's like
well we gotta get in on the action
with our dragon whoo is that a good
opening joke good rhyme thank you guys
everyone who's been watching our videos
this week sorry we're so late to
checking out this trailer let's
do it all right guys remember what we're
looking for
and don't trust anyone
don't trust where are your anyone
hey uh who's baby
yeah this looks great
[Music]
[Applause]
we could use someone like you let's
catch you up she's like
from from fullmetal raya for as long as
we can remember
my daughter i believe our people can
come together again
but someone has to take the first step
this music is cool
i know it's great
oh no no no should be great by the end
don't worry
whoa ah this looks really so cool this
looks like a really good one yeah
this looks like an action damn and just
like yeah the the
focal lengths they're going with yeah i
feel like it's gonna be a lot more
intense than the trailers leading on
a lot of really cool wide angles man
they're gonna be inspiring each other
raya and the dragon
whoa
oh it is going to disney plus oh look
out oh
that's too bad you know i don't know why
i said that i
i'm not if i'm totally okay
without endangering their lives and
doing so
i'm so used to 20 20 being like no wait
and then now i'm at a point i'm like i'm
cool
let's watch more movies now that i've
watched it on a tv i think i'll be
going through a character arc here with
the streaming services in the movie
theaters yeah
like yeah i'm cool i'm cool now although
to be fair this does look like a movie
that would be very cool to see on a very
big screen it does
it really does i love that it's a south
east asian representation that's right
pinoy pride over here yes i'm filipino
are we southeast asian
yes according to the wikipedia page you
are among the many
southeast asians making sure he's that
were uh studied and visited in order to
that's what i'm talking about i remember
the escrima sticks being here in the
teaser trailer in pure disney marketing
fashion the fur the teaser trailer is
kind of like more serious in its tone it
doesn't really show you
the humor it had a lot of people kind of
thinking of the legend of korra or
avatar the last airbender and while
there's still some remnants of that
throughout it doesn't feel like it's
just a spin on that
it actually has its own voice this has
the humor that you kind of expect from
disney i imagine that it would probably
be a little bit more akin
to perhaps moana in the sense that if
you cut out the musicals of moana like
there's humor within the characters but
there's this real like epic grand scale
and sweeping
themes and emotions throughout i think
it's gonna really
delve heavily into like the warrior
elements i feel like the first half
might have a lot of humor but i think
the last half would be like
really epic serious crazy even though
they got aquafina as a dragon i'm really
thinking
the last half will be a lot more serious
in tone well that's the thing is like i
don't know aquafina's really funny but
also
weirdly enough like in that last jumanji
movie like some of the more perilous
moments like that involved her she
actually kind of pulled me
in with some of that not like full-on
gravitas because you know it's jumanji
but yeah like i feel like referencing
jumanji you know she had like a great
independent drama which i haven't seen
so i cannot reference you're going to
welcome to the jungle
uh doesn't matter the revenge doesn't
matter talk about how great she was
clearly i need to watch the farewell but
aquafina yes is
is an actress who has proved that she's
got the chops and so while yes like she
does look especially like the kind of
driver of the comedy for a lot of this i
feel like yeah she is a person who
doesn't feel like they were just cast
for the meme or for the name recognition
it's like i feel like she probably could
deliver a moving performance that has
her unique voice
you know delivering yes and i'm really
happy kelly marie tran gets a chance to
voice his character
too she's coming off of the rise of
skywalkers
right man it's cool that she gets the
opportunity to be in here you know like
sometimes a voiceover actress can really
be recognized for you know like
ming now wen has been in the spotlight a
lot lately with the mandalorian
funny enough for me as a kid my
association with ming know when was
mulan like i was
very much aware ming na one voiced her
and then i started becoming aware of her
presence even more
so i i don't i don't know if it'll have
that same level of weight or association
yeah i think that's still really cool
for her it's still a cool opportunity
the action sequences do look brilliant
in here
weirdly enough the movie i've heard
reference most this morning just of
people batting the trailer around is
tomb raider and i feel like that's
actually a pretty decent touchstone
because it really does look like it's
going to have all that swashbuckling and
all that thrilling
really visually punchy you know
explosion
definitely but i think it's still going
to feel like a disney movie
yeah yeah it's going to feel like a
disney movie that
has you know epic and you know very
cultural
and deep elements but probably i will be
kind of light and punchy overall
what i think is really cool about what
they're doing with the sense of peril
throughout here
my god you know like the sense of peril
listening
to the guardian this is ruining this
video even more
what i love about the sense of peril i'm
getting from this
is that it's coming from opposing
villainous
characters sometimes i feel like lately
it hasn't really been
felt from that with disney movies i feel
like they've done a lot to be like
no it's not like a villain villain it's
more like a situation
right yeah they have to kind of overcome
yeah or elements or something like that
and then here the villains they they
don't really capitalize on them in here
but
there's i feel like maybe the villain in
here i've been in the sense that with
whatever history is imbued in the dna of
this character that she might have a
change of heart even though we don't
focus on this villain all that much and
surely
it feels like one of those change of
heart villages we're gonna have
co-existence
ending yeah it's like oh we shouldn't
have been fighting at all
because this is just this seems a lot
about raya and the last dragon having to
learn and you know i like the theme too
of them having to be vulnerable
and learning how to trust in others and
then themselves
learning to work together as a team
that's why i think the villain is gonna
have a change of heart that's right yeah
the theme seems to
imply that yeah and i can totally
imagine now the montage of like you know
early on
in our ancient history there was just a
thing that we couldn't get over and and
i wish we had done it better but then it
created this conflict we don't need to
be
fighting and then they'll come together
john they're asian
do the asian voice come on white man
do the asian he doesn't have to do it
thank you craig for a second i thought i
was gonna have to try
all right guys all the good will we made
with those godzilla videos
alright guys well what did you think of
this
trailer did it out do the last one are
you excited for it
duh blah blah blah answer something hit
that like button
subscribe click that notification bell
last but not least
hey you know what i want to shout out
today the asianest man i know
daniel gallagher also from scotland
gallagher
dude you're like that guy in the in the
skin of the the skittles commercial or
the or the starbursts or whatever
well you know why i really wanted him
shout him out why because
there's actually a perfect way to shout
him out for this video oh okay okay
he's scottish it's called the last
dragon oh together
we are whitewashing ryan last dragon
shout you out man the 90s dragon movie
tom connery and david thulas and dennis
quaint
you're the last dragon and the first
dragon you are in our tragedy
i hope you have a dragon filled year i
hope you set the world on fire in 2021
buddy
yes poured a lot of gold live in a cave
talk to hobbits
whatever you can do protect that
arkanstone yeah man
happy new year but i hope turns out to
be a good one